there were no path measures with
Margaret Thatcher she was the most loved
Prime Minister and the most hated the
one with the strongest info surely yet
the most vilified - yes I will have a
stake how did I kick Roz Lee's haven't
she stopped Britain going bust and
turned things around and made it
possible to govern Britain again
dominated Thatcherism for its absolutism
for its cruelty for its divisive Ness
she was undoubtedly a remarkable Prime
Minister one has to put her among the
major figures of the 20th century
without a doubt no one who lived it has
forgotten the Thatcher right decade it
casts a long shadow even today we feel
the effect of her personality her
policies and of Margaret Thatcher's
vision of Britain Britain when we came
into office was in the last chance
saloon and everyone realize I think
people realized that we really had to do
a lot of rather tough things about it
and Margaret had a clear vision of what
was necessary
it was conviction politics I know that's
become a jargon phrase but she had a
strong idea of what she wanted to do it
was based on what she thought was the
right thing to do strange to think it
now but they underestimated Margaret
Thatcher at first Ted Heath never got
over being dumped for an upstart
grocer's daughter the grand old Tories
were slightly baffled by her sudden rise
when Labour was swept from office in
1979 the country didn't really know what
to expect where there is discord may we
bring harmony
weathers Ella may we bring truth where
there is doubt may we bring faith and
where there's despair may we bring hope
but the Thatcherite revolution got off
to a faltering start tough measures to
bear down on inflation fueled the rise
in unemployment soon her poll ratings
were rock-bottom and the new PM had her
back to the wall to those waiting with
bated breath for that favorite media
catchphrase the u-turn I have only one
thing to say u-turn if you want to
the lady's not for turning obdurate
spirit would soon be put to the test in
an unexpected arena when the Argentinian
general Galtieri ordered his troops into
the Falkland Islands he could have had
no inkling of the determination with
which Margaret Thatcher would coordinate
the British counter-offensive it was a
very very brave thing to do it gets all
the odds 12,000 miles and we now know
that probably if one more capital ship
had gone down the whole response of the
British to the Argentinian invasion
would have failed by the time the
staging post of South Georgia fell to
British forces the martial spirit had
really taken hold god save the queen
what happens that what you cannot thank
you very much or eh I said that news and
congratulate our forces and the Marines
and once this bitter conflict had been
won those who doubted the Prime
Minister's military judgment found
themselves in a minority what was wrong
with rejoicing what is wrong with
rejoicing when you've achieved success
God there are some people in Britain and
this is what she was up again will never
ever ever give any credit to Britain
never rejoice in its success Margaret
Thatcher's approach to Northern Ireland
was uncompromising - she allowed 9ir a
hunger strikers to die in the maze
prison thereby reinforcing her status as
Republican terrorists number one target
in Brighton they came perilously close
but in retrospect for all the bloodshed
among those near to the Prime Minister
the bombing succeeded principally in
carving a further chapter in the
burgeoning Thatcher legend the fact that
we are gathered here now shocked but
composed and determined is a sign not
only that this attack has failed but
that all attempts to destroy democracy
by terrorism will fail
confounding powerful foes was becoming a
Margaret Thatcher trademark she
remembered well how striking miners help
defeat the heath government and if she
now relished the prospect of grinding
down the miners leader it was no less
than he'd have wished for her there was
a conscious effort to build up the coal
stocks to make sure the where
contingency provisions made fortunately
she was a good strategist Scargill it
was the most incompetent leader of an
army I've ever encountered to call a
coal strike at the beginning of the
summer to alienate all the coal miners
in my constituency in the rest of not
even sure by not holding a ballot he
could not laid his hand worse the
country was divided by a drawn-out and
pitiless dispute the spectacle of trades
unions being brought painfully to heal
angered some for others it was a vital
step clearing the path for business
enterprise and wealth creation I'll do
my bit I know you'll do yours
Thatcherism was now reaching its
high-water mark around north
privatisations yuppies conspicuous
consumption the works these British car
shares did you know they'll be
publishing the prospectus on November
the 25th I didn t want to apply you can
reserve one over the forum if you see
said tell him we and the Prime
Minister's band of admirers spread far
and wide
none more devoted than Ronald Reagan
Margaret ended our first meeting by
telling me we must stand together and
that's exactly what we've done
Margaret Thatcher had been among the
first to urge Reagan to deal with the
Soviet reformer Mikhail Gorbachev and as
the wool fell it was widely viewed as a
victory for her and her American
partners staunch defense of freedom as
Margaret Thatcher's reputation overseas
soared at home she was losing her grip
with opposition to her poll tax project
at fever pitch the Iron Lady began to
look obstinate and out of touch the
single most unpopular policy that any
government has followed for long as I
can remember the real tragedy is cabinet
colleagues deserted her and stuck the
knife in it's rather like sending your
opening batsman to the crease but only
for them to find the moment the first
balls are billed that their backs have
been broken before the game by the team
captain Michael Heseltine's
subsequent challenge for the leadership
holds the Prime Minister below the
waterline though at first she wouldn't
admit it where's my microphone it's here
Dana Mike now very pleased that I got
more than half the parliamentary party
and disappointed that it's not quite
enough to win on the first ballot
so I confirm it is my intention to let
my name go forward for the second ballot
we had one of our typically robust
conversation Jed you're being defeated
and I said but you've been defeated I'm
gonna be defeatist you won't win a
second ballot the party wants you to
stand down and so to her evident
bewilderment the party turfed its true
blue champion
al-taher ladies and gentlemen we're
leaving Downing Street for the last time
after eleven and a half wonderful years
and we're very happy that we leave the
United Kingdom in a very very much
better state than when we came here
eleven and a half years ago these
traumatic moments scarred the
Conservatives for her supporters it was
nothing short of treachery the party
Margaret Thatcher had drawn together
fell into years of squabbles and fierce
recrimination Margaret Thatcher still
influences our political world every
top-flight politician since has grappled
with the Thatcher legacy Tony Blair's
sweeping victory came after he had
reconciled his party with great swathes
of the Thatcherite project another
Labour prime minister who had fought her
tooth and nail later claimed to have
inherited her mantle of being at heart a
conviction politician and David
Cameron's route to office was smoothed
by a repudiation of the rough edges the
perceived selfishness at the heart of
Thatcherism she of all modern-day
politicians is the figure against which
others measure themselves measure their
aspirations measure their achievements
it's an unforgiving business if truth be
told there aren't many who benefit from
comparison with Margaret Thatcher